Andy thanks for talking about your book
today yeah I read it he's very
interesting thank you very much
I also all I just ask some questions
here about it because it's a it's a
great read you say in the book that
America Americans really can't live
within their means they import goods oil
credit from overseas and that an
imperial US foreign policy has been
instituted to keep these things flowing
into the United States but the classical
economists in the late 18th century and
19th century sort of demonstrated that
in imperial foreign policies are not
really cost effective that is the market
will bring these things in without the
use of military power why do you think
that the u.s. still has this sort of
policy well the I think the motive force
behind American empire and we should
specify here we mean in formal Empire
not colonial empire in the British model
I think the motive force behind informal
Empire really really has it has several
sources one of them is economic I mean
regardless of what economists may think
they have demonstrated there are still
people who believe that it's essential
to assert control over parts of the
world in order to maintain access to raw
resources that may or may not be a good
idea but it's the idea they have but I
think the the informal American Empire
also has ideological roots I mean the
subtitle my book talks about the end of
American exceptionalism I think most
maybe all historians of the United
States would acknowledge the importance
of this idea of American exceptionalism
in terms of shaping our behavior you
know a belief that were special a belief
that we have a special mission and
therefore should exercise unique
prerogatives that - I think helps to
predispose us to the kind of informal
Empire that we've created and then there
of course is the
the security element I mean in
particular after 9/11 this
administration understandably was really
seized by a determination to prevent
another 9/11 that's understandable that
was certainly good defensible
proposition or they went wrong though
was in thinking that the way to prevent
another 9/11 was in essence to expand
the informal American Empire by
establishing control over the what they
call the greater Middle East I'll get
into that in a few minutes I have I like
to ask more questions about that but
first I'd like to go to this idea that
you mentioned in your book about the the
fact that the US citizens are not really
been asked to sacrifice by George Bush
in this war on terror and that is
there's been no rationing no draft no
enlarged Armed Forces at least
significantly how should Americans be
asked to sacrifice in the war on terror
if any if they shall be I mean let's
let's then pause it for a second that
the global war on terror actually is is
is a good idea is a proper frame for
u.s. national security policy I don't
actually think that it is but let's
let's for the sake of argument say that
it is the global war on terror as
conceived by the Bush administration
really looked to bringing about the
transformation of the Islamic world they
said as much I mean Rumsfeld said that
publicly a week after 9/11 stating that
you know we have chosen to change the
way that they live
I personally think that that's a
preposterous ambition nonetheless that
was the ambition that the Bush
administration defined as at the center
of its strategy after 9/11 well if
you're going to undertake big ambitious
aims you better have substantial
resources in order to achieve them and
to the extent that the global war on
terror is focused on the word war here
really
to the exercise of American hard power
in order to achieve US strategic
objectives then it seems to me that it
was going to require a lot of hard power
so we ought to have substantially
expanded the size of US forces that in
and of itself would have required a
sacrifice on the part of the American
people because it probably would have
required us to reconsider the notion
that military service is simply a matter
of individual choice you know if you
feel like serving good for you if I
don't feel like serving well that's ok
too you need to you need to have a
different conception of the citizens
responsibility to defend the country if
you're going to have a great big army
well to have a great big army and to
embark upon and open into global war
also implies significant financial
outlays and so the second form of
sacrifice that might have been and
probably ought to have been required if
you believe in the Global War on Terror
is that we should have changed our
internal our domestic our economic
priorities I mean if you want to fight a
big war then we ought to pay for a big
war that means we should we should have
we ought to have changed our priorities
to de-emphasize consumption and
emphasize the kind of sacrifice or
contributions that would pay for the war
that the Bush administration designed
but you don't necessarily endorse that
big war on terror you think there should
be a different response no I think that
I think that the concept of a global war
on terror is fatally flawed again let's
understand what how the Bush
administration envisioned this global
war on terror the Iraq war really I
think is the most important illustrative
case the Bush strategy was based on the
expectations that we could invade and
occupy a place like Iraq achieve a
decisive and economical military victory
and then rather quickly be able to
reform or remake Iraq into something
like a liberal democracy
I mean I I am feel confident that they
viewed Iraq as kind of a demonstration
product our project that by showing our
willingness to use power in our capacity
to bring about significant change in
Iraq they believe the United States
would be in a position not necessarily
to invade and occupy every other country
in the region but would be in a position
to use our leverage to bring about
change in Iran in Syria in Egypt in
Pakistan you name it the problem the
problem was of course that the invasion
of Iraq did not yield a easy decisive
economical victory what it yielded was a
very protracted stalemate that has cost
us probably something like 800 billion
dollars over 4,000 American dead
probably something like 30,000 American
wounded and and let us not forget the
number of Iraqis who have been killed
and injured as a consequence of this
misadventure so do you think that this
could have possibly had the
counterproductive effect of showing
regimes in the future how to beat the
United States and any sort of war by
counterinsurgency rather than building
up huge armed forces like North Korea
and Saddam did well I think at a minimum
it demonstrated how that our military
power is actually much more limited than
most people imagined back in 2000 I mean
the the the attitude that most Americans
and certainly virtually everybody in the
in the mainstream political business the
attitude that that Americans had evolved
after the Cold War was one that insisted
that we were the greatest military power
the world had ever seen and seemed to
assume that any conflict that the United
States undertook would rather quickly
produce positive results well what we've
seen since 9/11 actually we should have
seen this even in the 1990s was that
that's an illusion you know it's not
simply that we're stuck in Iraq we are
also stuck in Afghanistan but I think
your point is also correct it's not
simply that the
the military history of the last decade
has demonstrated the limits of our power
it's also provided examples of how best
to fight the United States and you fight
the United States successfully if you
rely on unconventional means okay let's
rewind the tape here a little bit and
start with before 9/11 we've been
mentioning things that have happened
after 9/11 you say in the book that the
u.s. elite was preoccupied with
governing the Empire the informal Empire
and paid little attention to protecting
the US homeland of course it's just
difficult to dispute those facts I think
because of the nature of what's happened
but isn't it even worse than you say
Osama bin Laden has repeatedly said that
he attacks the United States because of
not it's non Muslim occupation of Muslim
lands which of which he includes Israel
occupying Palestine and also our support
of what he believes are corrupt Islamic
governments in other words don't our
attempts to control the Imperial
periphery actually generate attacks on
the US homeland well they certainly do
to some degree I mean it is not to
become a shill for Osama bin Laden to
acknowledge that one source of his
gripes and indeed one source of the
grievances of many Muslims directed
towards the United States is u.s.
foreign policy I mean the the statement
that President Bush once made about they
they hate us for our freedoms is is not
only untrue but it's also it also
results in misleading ourselves we we
need not endorse or or accept or approve
of their views but we need to at least
acknowledge and recognize them u.s.
policy going back decades has been one
of the reasons that we find ourselves in
in the mid
of this of this conflict so would you
say that the American people haven't
focused on this aspect this connection
with our foreign policy given the fact
that the president has sort of mentioned
them some things that the polling in the
Arab world and the Islamic world really
don't show that they hate us for our
economic and political freedoms but one
aspect of this as you mentioned is are
this very specific foreign policies that
bin Laden keeps bringing up all over and
over in fact he gave one speech that
said Bush is lying this is what I'm
attacking and no one's condoning the the
monstrous attacks that the muddin
orchestrated on 9/11 but why do you
think there's been so little
introspection in the United States about
why he's attacking I mean he said it
very clearly why he's attacking and why
are the American people reluctant to
even examine this issue well it's not
that all the American people think one
way or think another way but it does
seem to me to be the case that a very
large number of our fellow citizens are
are content with a kind of mythic
version of American history are
unwilling to examine exactly how we rose
to a position of global primacy what we
really did to whom we did it and who
ended up paying the cost the story of
Americans ruiner of America's rise to
preeminence is dramatic remarkable a
story of spectacular success over a
period of 150 years or close to 200
years but it's not a particularly moral
story it's not an uplifting story and
it's a story in which along the way we
not only made many different mistakes
but we also inflicted wrongs on
different people now that doesn't mean
we should somehow walk around with you
know ashes on our head and be apologetic
but we need to understand that our our
history is not a history of black and
white our history is a history of many
shades of grey I think compounding our
difficulty the difficulty of seeing our
relations with the Muslim world clearly
is the fact that at least until very
recently that part of the world was very
much
peripheral as far as we saw it I mean I
was born in 1947 and I have to say
growing up and even as a young adult I
thought basically the story of the world
was the was the Cold War I mean it was
this enormous confrontation between the
Soviet empire in the West and of course
that was one story of what the world was
about in the late 40s and 50s and 60s
and 70s but there was another story and
yet the other story was the the the
collapse of European control in the
Middle East the rise of Arab nationalism
the creation of Israel a series of
military conflicts ever-growing Western
dependence on on on Middle Eastern oil
and a record of us miscalculation that
actually ended up creating problems I
mean one example would be the u.s.
British overthrow of the Mossadegh
regime in Iran in 1953 and then the
reinstallation of the Shah on the on the
throne when I was a kid I think I
understood that there was some
involvement in that episode it didn't
seem to be particularly important Iran
was not a particularly important country
in my conception of the way the world
works but in this juncture of history
from 2008 looking back to 9/11 and then
trying and looking before 9/11 at how we
got to 9/11 well the decision to
overthrow
that elected government into reinstall
the Shah was a blunder of of enormous
proportions we need to recognize that
and we need to understand the extent to
which it our own actions contributed to
the conflict in which we find ourselves
would you also put in the category of
blunders Ronald Reagan's support of the
Mujahideen it started under Carter but
Ronald Reagan really ramped it up and
bin Laden sprang out of this chaos and
this support of these radical Islamic
rioters I don't think I'd call it a
blunder but I think that's a perfect
illustration of how complex history is
how difficult it is to understand the
consequences of your actions of the
irony of history you know Carter and
then Reagan didn't intervene in support
of the Mujahideen because they had any
inkling of what we would kind of the
monster we would help be helping to
create it was because they saw this as
an opportunity in the context of the
Cold War to it to exploit an advantage
against the Soviet Union to make the
Soviets bleed and if you look at the at
the episode in that framework it was
masterful it was brilliant
it did help to bring the Cold War to an
end and help bring down the Soviet
empire but it also ended up doing a
variety of other things that have have
have hurt us deeply
so blunder not really an example of the
ironic aspect of history emphatically so
yeah well I guess it's a great thing to
have the Soviet Union dissolved but it's
it's another to also create one of the
most severe threats to the homeland that
we've ever faced probably since the war
of 1812 maybe we haven't faced a threat
to the continental United States at
least as bin Laden poses I'd like to go
over some of the other effects of the
war on terror now
you argue that the quasi permanent
crisis during the Cold War and the war
on terror has disastrous disastrously
distorted our Constitution and that the
US public has allowed that to happen
could you be a little bit more specific
about that because that's really
something that doesn't get much
attention what happens in any war
overseas to the Republic here at home
well I mean I'm really referring here to
the rise of the imperial presidency
President Bush has taken many many hits
I think the charges that he has really
abused the power of his office in many
ways I think those charges in most cases
are appropriate but we need to remember
that the problem didn't begin with
President Bush I mean the the imperial
presidency is an outgrowth of you
probably could actually trace it's its
beginnings even to the depression but
certainly is an outgrowth of World War
two and then emphatically an outgrowth
of that protracted national security
emergency called the called the Cold War
but the imperial presidency didn't come
into existence because presidents were
seizing authority and seizing power in
my judgment it came into existence
because the Congress was thrusting power
and authority at the president
especially on anything to touch even
remotely on national security and we the
people I think also were complicit in
that at least since the election of John
Kennedy in in 1960 we have indulged in
an image of the president you know the
so-called most powerful man in the world
the so-called leader of the free world
indulge in an image that that treated
the president as a demigod as a figure
who who was expected to save the day fix
all the problems and that was always an
illusion in in part because no matter
how smart
our president is he or she is not going
to be smart enough to truly understand
every aspect of the way the world works
but also because even the most imperial
president actually has to work within a
variety of constraints some of those
constraints are domestic certainly some
of those constraints come from beyond
our borders
so we erected this we we elevated the
President to a position of primacy above
the other branches of government that
has not served us well and it really
seems to me that it's past time for us
to return to a model of governance that
more closely reflects the original
intentions of the of the framers of the
Constitution and it seems like many
Americans aren't clear that the that the
system that gets so much rhetorical
support even adulation may not be this
is the system that was originally
intended by the founders it seems like
the founders wanted a more powerful
Congress maybe a lesser executive and
certainly more power to the states but
it seems like as you mentioned the
presidency has grown ever since
Roosevelt and Truman up to the point of
where it's just overshadowing the other
branches so and yours did you say in the
book that Congress is basically given
all its power away simply because the
congressmen are more and and senators
are more interested in getting reelected
through gerrymandering and pork-barrel
spending than they are you know
defending their prerogatives against
executive encroachment how what caused
the founders system to break down and
how do we get the Congress to get back
into the game how do we change this
incentive system and where the founders
did they make a flawed system I mean
that's a bold question but it seems to
have broken down somewhere when we had
congressional a congressional government
up until probably the spanish-american
war and then after that the executive
started William McKinley on where it
started encroaching maybe even before
that
with the Civil War Lincoln but how do we
get the Congress back in the game I'm
not hopeful that any of this is going to
happen I think you put your finger on
the key thing get Congress back in the
game get get Congress to functioning as
a body that's interesting and fulfilling
it's it's its constitutional
responsibilities that that takes
precedence over party or partisan issues
get get a get a membership in Congress
that somehow is committed to some vision
of the common good rather than simply
committed to servicing the needs are the
desires of different interest groups
with particular attention to the ones
that are going to get them reelected
that's never going to happen unless we
begin to elect different people than we
elect we're never going to elect
different people as long as we're stuck
I think with the two-party system that
we have so I think we really need to
have another another a wider choice a
more distinctive choice which probably
means the creation of a third party and
of course you know and I know that
that's been attempted any number of
times in modern American political
history and it never gets very far the
system usually snuffs it outright in
some way yeah so it seems like well you
know when we had a congressional
government in the 19th century before
the spanish-american war we seem to have
a fewer foreign interventions than we do
as the rise with the rise of the
executive because it's easier for the
executive to wield power on the
battlefield and is how many of our
hundreds of members of Congress we had
at whatever particular time in American
history so I think what you're saying it
seems to me is that a foreign policy of
a country is supposed to support its
domestic system nurture it safeguard it
protect it but in this case it may have
been flipped in the 20th century and we
went to a system that's more where the
domestic system is being sacrificed to
keep the interventionist foreign policy
alive is that what you're saying yeah I
mean in in essence I'm saying but I mean
now I I guess I'd want to make an
point you know it's not simply the fact
that we have a president who wields
power contributing to the problem is the
type of person that the president
surrounds himself with I mean one of the
things I talked about in the book for at
least a few pages is the the rise of a
national security elite again pretty
much after World War Two and then
through the Cold War of people who claim
to have real expertise and national
security affairs but who who tend in
fact to inflate the threat and who also
tend in my judgment to be too quick to
see the remedy to the threat through
military action either either either
raising up military power or in fact
using military power so this this
tradition of the national security elite
I sort of trace it back to James
Forrestal the the first secretary of
defense in contrast that really to the
earlier tradition of Henry Stimson this
new national security elite too to
easily panics to too quick to insist on
some kind of resolution to intolerant of
of risk to insistent that we need to
enjoy perfect security and that hasn't
served as well how most of that change
do you think relates to that what
Eisenhower called the
military-industrial complex that is we
have a dedicated defense industry rather
than the industry that we had before
where when there was a war the civilian
industry changed over to military
production and then changed completely
back are almost completely back after
the war and during the Truman
administration we began to have a
permanent defense industry and they
begin to lobby for these things and the
the indication isn't direct and it
doesn't explain all of US foreign policy
or national security policy but to what
extent do you think that elite is a
reflective of the vested interests
pushing for some of these interventions
well it is to some degree of course
because
there's plenty of evidence that shows
that members of the national security
elite when their parties are to power
not infrequently end up being part of
the military-industrial complex and then
when their party comes back and the
power they lead to military industrial
complex and you know get another job in
the Department of Defense having said
that I think it's important not to
overstate the influence of the
military-industrial complex there is a
military-industrial complex
it does have influence in Washington DC
there's no question about that but the
level of military spending today roughly
what four percent of our GDP is not
nearly as great as it once was during
the Cold War
so my own sense is that I guess the real
point would be I go I give talks to
different groups and almost inevitably
there's somebody in the audience is
going to say come on isn't the answer to
everything the military-industrial
complex and that's who's pulling the
strings you also get the same argument
from somebody that says isn't it true
that it's the Israel lobby that's
pulling the strings and that's the
answer
well there is an Israel lobby there is a
military-industrial complex but to claim
that either one is pulling all the
strings is to attribute to them far more
influence than they actually have and
also is then - it's it's too easy an
answer that if we give that answer we
sort of let ourselves off the hook a
little bit and in my judgment we the
people share a level of responsibility
in whatever it is that ails the country
at a particular time whether we're
talking about the financial crisis that
we're all concerned about right now or
whether we're talking about a foreign
policy that is fundamentally misguided
mmm okay we've got to take a break now
but we'll be back afterwards and several
other c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts visit book tv.org
more with Andrew bacevich and Ivan
Eiland in a moment on October 15th the
National Book Foundation announced the
finalists for the 2008 National Book
Awards in nonfiction the dark side the
inside story of how the war on terror
turned into a war on American ideals by
Jane Mayer this Republic of suffering
death and the American Civil War by drew
Gilpin Faust the Hemmings is a
Monticello an American family by Annette
gordon-reed final salute a story of
unfinished lives by Jim Schuyler and the
suicide index putting my father's death
in order by john wickersham the winners
of the 2008 National Book Awards will be
announced on November 19th afterwards
with Andrew bacevich and Ivan eland
continues okay we're back now and you
were talking about the defense budget
and how big it was and in the book you
say it's up to 700 billion a year and I
suppose if you add foreign aid veterans
spending interest on the debt as it
pertains to Defense Department of Energy
nuclear programs you probably come with
a security budget of you know probably
double that but you also note in the
book that entitlements went up
drastically after 9/11 and it seems
throughout US history that we've always
had an increase in domestic spending and
at the same time we have a big war and
that's very curious it seems maybe that
the whatever parties and power has to
pay the opposition off for the war or
what do you huh you mentioned this you
sort of don't link them directly in the
book but I think conservatives
oftentimes missed the point that warfare
is the biggest cause of government big
government in in world history and that
oftentimes the non-security budget
expands during peace during wartime
this is what I would speculate about the
current case that is to say about the
global war on terror after 9/11 when the
Bush administration conceived of this
very ambitious plan to transform the
Islamic world they bet that the military
as it existed in 2001 was going to be
sufficient to get the job done that's
why they didn't expand the the army its
way didn't expand the Marine Corps
because what we had was supposed to
suffice at the same time they also
didn't turn to the American people and
say well we're gonna raise your taxes
but instead President Bush but 10 days
after 9/11 explicitly it was an
appearance I think in Chicago said go
down to Disneyworld enjoy life the way
we want it to be lived and it's my view
that one of the reasons that they urged
Americans to carry on as if there were
no war is that they expected that that
would give the administration greater
latitude and how do they conduct the war
it would by divorcing the American
people from the actual conduct of the
war by basically sand there's no need
for you to pay attention then they would
be able to make the kinds of decisions
they would not be constrained when they
undertook things like an invasion of
Iraq and of course in the near term in a
sense that worked you know you may
remember that in the run-up to the
invasion of Iraq on the one hand both in
the US and abroad there were some very
impressive popular demonstrations of
opposition to the war I happened to be
in in New York City on that weekend when
all the big protests were and it was it
was really quite remarkable the number
of people who turned out in the streets
but those concerns really didn't
translate into any effective constraints
in the president
you know he got his resolution in the in
the US Congress and because of the
expanded imperial presidency
well again given to him authority given
to him by the by the Congress so I think
that that in this case the distribution
of largesse the tax cuts during a time
of war the promise of increased
entitlements like the prescription drug
program in a time of war was motivated
at least in part by the calculation that
we could buy the people off with bread
and circuses and therefore we'd be able
to conduct our war the way we wanted to
be conducted and as I suggested it
worked for a while it worked long enough
for the president to be elected to a
second term I think now here in this
moment of financial crisis we're seeing
the folly of that approach go to war
spend more abroad and fighting your Wars
at the same time that you're going to
spend more at home that's not prudent
statecraft so you think if that's a
major cause of the current financial
meltdown major cause may go too far is
that is that part of it is that related
absolutely mm-hmm so it seems like
george w bush likes to compare himself
with ronald reagan but wouldn't it be a
more appropriate comparison be to Lyndon
Johnson and Richard Nixon our last
liberal presidents because they're both
you he's doing tried to do guns and
butter at the same time he's trying to
do guns and butter and and and you know
the techniques are different but you
probably can draw some comparisons
between george w bush and lyndon johnson
in the the the level of deception that
accompanied their wars i mean it's clear
now I guess it's been clear for a long
time in the eyes of some that the
Johnson administration engaged in really
a wholesale deception with regard to us
entrance into Vietnam and
the Vietnam War was about and how it was
going to be fought and what it was going
to what it was going to cost and we have
seen at least something of the same
since since 9/11 especially with regard
to Iraq now you mentioned Iraq one of
the underlying causes that some people
think that we went to war in Iraq was to
gain increased control over the Persian
Gulf oil now of course that would be
denied by the administration but this is
whether that's the case or not we seem
to hear that and you mentioned this in
the book that being dependent on foreign
oil is bad almost universally across the
spectrum we see all these TV ads various
people telling us that but in the 1940s
the thinking was the opposite if price
was going up either because of shortages
or potential shortages or because oil
was important for national security why
not use other people's oil and keep ours
till a later date and so I'm wondering
if this is really sort of a canard that
we hear that being dependent on foreign
oil is bad certainly having cheap oil
and being dependent on foreign oil go
together because it's much cheaper to
produce Saudi Arabia and Iraq are the
lowest cost producers in the world and
the Persian Gulf oil is very low so we
have high cost oil here so it seems like
maybe this alleged security issue of
being dependent on foreign oil isn't bad
after all the market seems to get the
oil here no matter what we do because
these countries have 65 to 95 percent of
their our revenues from oil so they it's
about oil the valuable commodity they
want to sell it to get the revenues how
do you see the oil market influencing
these types I guess I'm going to be
stubborn and insists that stick to my
judgment that dependence on foreign
countries for our energy security is a
bad thing and I think it's a bad thing
let's go back to the original point you
know some people argue that the reason
we went to war was to lock up the oil
well that's not true I mean as you say
and before we invaded Iraq they were
selling oil isn't it's not as if Saddam
Hussein was keeping it all to him was
gay it was keeping it all to himself
having said that we never would have
gone to war in Iraq were it not for the
fact that the Persian Gulf is the center
of the world's oil reserves that's at
least indirectly so the region wouldn't
we would not care a lick about that that
part of the world were it not for the
fact that that's where the oil is we
would we would we would care as much
about Saudi Arabia if Saudi Arabia
didn't have oil we would care as much
about Saudi Arabia as we care about or
agua all right
so in that sense yes of course it's
about oil because oil is what makes that
part of the world what lends to that
part of the world its strategic
significance and I would argue that if
we look at US policy going back 50 years
or so back back to when Roosevelt met
with King ebin Saud and made that
commitment to the security of the of the
Saudi royal family that be the
determination of American policymakers
to at first maintain stability in the
region at least since 1980 their
determination to achieve u.s. dominion
in the region has led to a pattern of
meddling and increasingly beginning in
1980 militarized meddling that is
radically at odds with our our interests
and were we energy independent or even
could we have some approximation of
energy independence then it seems to me
that the rationale for this meddling and
for the tendency to intervene would
evaporate to put it another way if we
weren't depend on other dependent upon
others for energy then it would be we
would be much more likely to be able to
choose war rather than somehow feeling
that we were that it was incumbent upon
us not to go to war as has been the case
in the Middle East for the for the past
15-20 years now the if you would say
that our our oil policy resembled that
of the Imperial Japan you'd get a big
pushback from a lot of people really
quickly but if you look at what the
Japanese were after in Indonesia that
which started World War two this idea
that we need to go after resources at
gunpoint is is quite troubling morally
and it seems to me that we we don't we
don't like to think of it in those terms
because it would be it would be shocking
to some people but if you look at the
actual facts involved you can you get
some you know comparisons that aren't to
me that I guess it goes back to what
you're saying is we have to be more
Americans have to be less idealistic and
more realistic about our history but
ourselves I mean because I was going to
say that's where sort of the garnish of
American idealism gets added to US
policy I mean if someone were to compare
Japanese imperialism in Southeast Asia
with American imperialism in in the
Middle East
the typical American pushback would be
that yeah but but they were oppressive
which indeed they were where I was no
doubt about that whereas we bring
liberal values we bring democracy we
bring freedom well there have been times
in our history where one of the
consequences of interventionism has been
to bring liberal values but that's never
been the driving purpose of US policy
and there certainly have been many
occasions when the results of American
intervention did not bring or brought
anything but liberal values so yes I do
think that our conversation simply
emphasizes how urgent it is for us to be
able to look ourselves in a mirror and
see who we are and understand exactly
what are what what is the history that
brought us to where we are today why do
you think Americans are so susceptible
to these the soaring ideological
rhetoric or patriotic rhetoric when
other you go to other countries and they
the public is much more attuned to the
fact that their country has to do things
and they do things for their interests
but in in the United States we always is
this America one example of American
exceptionalism that we tend to as you
put a garnish our history and garnish
what we're doing we're bringing
democracy to places when we may be doing
the opposite as in Chile in 1973 or
Dominican Republic in 1965 yeah well I
mean two things first is I mean there
have been other great powers that also
have sort of cultivated this mythic
sense of who they are
the British camp the British Empire
would be an example and the French
Empire I think would be an example also
but I do think that the prints of the
principle explanation lies in this this
concept of American exceptionalism what
why is it so persistent well in part
because it is of such mistake I mean it
really does go back to John Winthrop
1630 on the deck of the Arabella and
declaring to his follower
that we shall be as a city upon the hill
that in all the world is watching us
that we have been chosen by God and that
that that concept really ends up being a
thread that just runs through the course
of American history I'm it makes me
laugh to hear Republicans these days
credit the phrase city upon a hill to
Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan used it
frequently but he was very shrewdly and
skillfully you know tapping a concept
that that existed long long long before
he entered mainstream politics it did
this idea of American exceptionalism
we're special we have a special mission
we should exercise special prerogative
that did actually serve our interests
for a time it was not true but it was
useful the problem today is it's still
not true but now it's not useful matter
of fact I think it's pernicious that it
would be far more useful in terms of
providing a basis for policy for us to
see ourselves as one nation among many a
nation that has achieved much but has
also made errors along the way a nation
that does not contrary to the claims
made by almost anybody running for high
office a nation that does not have some
perfect vision on how the world supposed
to turn out and where it's supposed to
go we really don't know those things and
we should be we should have sufficient
humility to acknowledge that now one of
the refreshing things about your book is
that it's very honest blunt sometimes
even blunt and one of the things that
you mention is that the that the main
historical mission of the United States
has been expansion rather than freedom
and in fact I think you say that we take
freedom to mean consuming anything that
we want that's what the modern day
version of it is but I want to go back
in time a little bit and say maybe we
should make a distinction between
external idealism and internal idealism
in fact we could we could recognize that
our country is does things for our own
interests instead of high overblown
inflated rhetoric while at the same time
we could appreciate that our country has
certain freedoms and at the domestic
system that was created at least at the
start which admittedly has changed over
time was certainly unique at the time
and was a you know that I think the
first republic on a large scale in world
history and the founders I don't think
we're totally cynical and being
expansion being the goal because I think
George Washington talked about avoiding
permanent alliances and establishing
commercial but not political
relationships with foreign country
countries in other words stay out of
other people's business and I think
Thomas Jefferson sort of made it
bipartisan back then by saying by
railing against entangling alliances so
it seemed like they were much less
inclined to get involved and overseas
Wars at the time or do you think that
that was just all rhetoric and that no I
mean they were they were realists and
they recognized that given the relative
weakness of the United States in 1790
and 1818 xx and 1870 it would have been
folly for us to allow ourselves to be
drawn into great power competition great
power Wars of the sort that were quite
common in Europe at the same time I
would argue that from the outset
American statesmen embarked upon a
project that looked to acquiring more
power in the 19th century to include mr.
Jefferson that tended to focus first on
the acquisition of new markets
commercial opportunity commercial
enterprise and second it focused on the
acquisition of territories I mean in our
elementary school textbooks we somehow
imagined that the expansion of the 13
original States clinging to the eastern
seaboard into a nation that expands the
end you know from sea to shining sea we
somehow thought that that was part of
our domestic politics it wasn't that was
the essence of foreign policy acquire
Louisiana acquire Florida war with
Mexico acquire Texas acquire the
Southwest California integrate all that
territory into the Union and into the
into a national political economy that
was the that was the big project of the
19th century and it was fabulously
successful it was expansion and by the
end of the 19th century thanks to that
project that project of expansionism the
United States was already basically the
richest country in the world in the 20th
century expansionism took a different
form miheer that brief episode around
the time of the spanish-american War
were expansionism means secure colonies
but that brief experiment didn't last
very long but if you look at the first
50 60 70 years of the 20th century
expansionism now really becomes the
effort to create the informal Empire
it's an expansion ISM that focuses on on
creating an open and integrated
international economic order so we can
trade and in those days when we traded
the advantage accrued to us not to the
Chinese it focused on on enabling us to
have not only economic access but also
military access so that we could project
power it focused on trying to maintain
stability it to a degree it focused on
trying to inculcate American
and it focused on trying to achieve
hegemony in the parts of the world that
were the most important and by the time
we get to the end of World War two
that's Western Europe and North East let
me stop you right there because I think
after the Cold War ended it seemed like
we went away from that policy and went
into every region whether it was
important or not did use DC I think I
think you're exactly right when the cold
when the cold war ends I speaking for
myself I somewhat naively thought well
now we've won the big contest in modern
history so I guess we can kind of go
back to me in a normal nation in fact
the end of the Cold War simply saw
really enhanced American ambition and
enhanced our determination to wield
power and to maintain our primacy you
know it's in the 90s that we get all the
big talk about sole superpower
indispensable nation unipolar moment end
of history all the chest-thumping
really is is heard in the 1990s that's
when I think the exaggerated sense of
American power in an exaggerated sense
of America's understanding of history
gets us in trouble now if I could just
back up a second
in that story of expansion where we
acquire ever greater power
we also acquire ever greater material
abundance my argument is that by
extension because we are so powerful and
because we enjoy such prosperity we're
also able to make strides towards
creating that more perfect union it's
because we're rich that that our
political system gains a certain
elasticity and we're able to deal with
social problems by cutting people into
the American dream whether we're talking
about blacks that we're talking about
Latinos that we're talking about women
however beginning at about the 1960s the
positive correlation between
expansion power abundance and freedom
I think begins to become undone and this
expansion since the 1960s and especially
the effort expansion since 9/11 the
Global War on Terror is is is leading us
to squander our power
it's undercutting our prosperity and
just go check the market and I think is
also compromising our freedom because
we've got an imperial president who is
unwilling to acknowledge any real limits
on his power so I think you've made a
good case for that we do have Imperial
overextension going on I think even
national greatness conservatives may may
agree with you because of the Iraq war
because of the financial crisis etc but
let's move to your solution to this you
advocate substituting for the bush
doctrine of preventative preventive war
a doctrine of containment of radical
Islam using selective engagement now
under this policy what criteria we used
to decide whether we take military
action or not well I think you left a
piece out here and in the pieces exactly
what is the threat that we face right
after 9/11 all of us were frightened too
many of us I think bought into the
comparisons of al-qaeda to Nazi Germany
and that Osama bin Laden was the new
Adolf Hitler that was a depiction of the
threat that made the idea of open-ended
global war have a certain possibility
but it seems clear at this juncture that
we vastly overstated that threat there
is a threat there are terrorist
organizations like al-qaeda
they do want to kill us but I think
there means their capabilities are
actually relatively modest so rather
than seeing them as some horrendous
entity that we should wage
war against from now for the next five
decades I think we should see al Qaeda
in similar organizations as
manifestations of an international
criminal conspiracy they are hoodlums
and you deal with an international
criminal conspiracy not by invading
countries and occupying them but by
siccing the cops on them and if you want
to go back to more of a law enforcement
model rather than the war on terrorism
that the Bush administration
that's exactly right but let me
emphasize because you know the the the
the the law enforcement model somehow
conjures up images of you know a
policeman on the beat wearing a blue
uniform and you know twirling his stick
I'm talking about an international
police effort that would be sustained
intensive and very very well resourced
that would identify these networks and
root them out now if we've spent
something like seven or eight hundred
billion dollars to the present day in
Iraq
what would a hundred billion dollars
have have achieved with regard to
rooting al-qaeda out of of Afghanistan
and Pakistan for the over the last seven
years I think we could have achieved a
lot so so it's not simply a policy of
containment it's actually a policy or a
strategy that that is is founded on a
very aggressive police effort you mean
by their doubt the people who want to
kill us you mean by that
police forces exchanging information and
arresting other people and again police
forces here as in national police forces
I mean in American context the FBI the
CIA probably from time to time the
special operations forces of the
military but aimed at destroying the
network not thinking that the way to do
that is to invade and occupy a country
like Iraq or or for that matter
Afghanistan okay one last question so we
get to the what we should do now what
about the forces in the book
you say well first of all Secretary of
Defense Bob gates just made a speech
saying you know we really have to count
we really have to concentrate on
counterinsurgency rather than
conventional forces
he didn't say go away from conventional
forces completely but he criticized the
military for not fighting the right war
what do you think about that and what
type of a military force would you want
to have to do that Gates is committed to
fighting the global war on terror he
thinks that's the proper framework of
strategy if you think it's a proper
framework of strategy then yeah we
better have a counterinsurgency an army
because they're going to be fighting
counterinsurgencies from now until the
cows come home I can understand the
logic of that I just don't think that we
should be waging this global war on
terror I think the the small wars in
which we find ourselves in Afghanistan
in Iraq really are imperial wars they
really are an effort on the part of a
foreign population to impose its will on
a local population and that's not
necessary it seems to me for us to
achieve our national security interests
so my argument is not whether or not the
army should be conventional or
unconventional the argument I'd like to
take up is whether or not the global war
on terror makes sense or whether there
should be an alternative to the global
war on terror I believe there should be
and if you change that strategy